السلطات العسكريه في مقاطعه سيدي نيبرو
جنوب البلاد وجنوبه اوكرانيا بمقتل
المدنيين واصابه ثلاثه في قصف روسيه
استهدف المدينه الصناعيه في مدينه
الاركان الاوكرانيه الى قواتها سنه 19
غاره على مواقع تمركز القوات الروسيه في
اكثر من محور على طول خطوط التماس
هيئه الاركان الاوكرانيه بمقتل اكثر من 10
جنود الروس واصابه نحو 30 في قصر اوكرانيا
استهدف من طاقه في مقاطعه زابولوجيا
جنوبيه البلاد
الصاروخي باسقاطي مروحيه روسيه من طراز 52
مؤكدت هيئه الاركان الاوكرانيه تصديها له
هجمه القوه الروسيه في ثلاثه في 13 منطقه
في دباس اضافه الى اربع محاولات على مدينه
بخموت
افادت السلطات المحليه المواليه لروسيا في
لوغانس بان ثلاثه اشخاص قتلوا واصيب 15
بجروح في قسم استهدف مناطق عده في
المقاطعه
المحليه لروسيا الى 12
خلال 24
هذا اليوم
دنيا
سلام خضر سلام عن هذا القصف المستمر على
دنيا وما خلفه
مريم سنبدا من لوجان قبل نحو نصف ساعه
اعلنت السلطات المحليه هناك ان تسعه اشخاص
قتلوا بقصف صباحي قبل نحو ساعتين يبدو ان
القصف استهدف بحسب السلطات المحليه احد
المباني المخصصه لايواء عمال بناء قالت
السلطات المحليه ان هؤلاء العمال يتواجدون
في لوغانسك في لمساعده السلطات المحليه
على اعاده اعمار ما هدمته هذه الحرب
الاستهداف بحسب السلطات المحليه تم لمبنا
اذا سكني بحسب وصف السلطات هناك باربعه
صواريخ هاي مارس وقبل اقل من 10 دقائق
قالت السلطات هناك ان القصفه تجدد على
الجي فاسكو حتى الان نحن ننتظر ورود اي
تحديث على اعداد القتلى او الجرح هناك هذا
في لوغانس هنا دونيت كانت ليلى عصيبه على
المدينه لم يتوقف خلالها القصف المد ولكن
اللافت كان عند فجر هذا اليوم
استهدفت المدينه
بعشره صواريخ جراند سقطت في احياء وسط
مدينه دمياط اسفر عن سقوط اصابات من دون
وقوع قتلى ومن ضمن همم الاماكن التي تم
استهدافها بحسب السلطات المحليه كنيسه
ومعها التقني اضافه الى عدد من الصواريخ
سقطت قرب محطه للشرطه المحليه في هذه
الاثناء نؤكد ان هناك قصف متبادل عند خطوط
الجبهه في دنياك بين الجيشين الروسي
والاوكراني هذا القصف طبيعي لا يتوقف ولكن
حدته هذا الصباح يبدو انها اكثر كثافه من
الايام السابقه مريم شكرا جزيلا لك سلام
خضر كنت معنا من دنيا